so what was a Gilded Age and why did it
happen the Gilded Age is this
fascinating period from about 1870 to
1908 s' a little bit but that's so we're
talking post-civil war America becomes
an industrial powerhouse the cities rise
so in 1850 fewer people live in the
cities than in the rural part of the
country by 1900 more people in 1900
in the cities and basically you have the
birth of the railroads the railroads get
connected in 1869 going all the way
Continental railroad going all the way
across the country you have the rise of
oil as and John Rockefeller and
basically this period think of
Rockefeller and Vanderbilt as and
Carnegie and JP Morgan as powerful the
way we think of presidents presidents
during this period kind of work on the
Descent but the but the magnets of
industry railroad oil steel those were
all banking those were the superheroes
in America and they led to this amazing
growth in industrialization
but then also huge disparities no labor
laws that we would be familiar with
today so you had this industrialization
with people working in the industries
who had no protections child labor
working 22 hours a day horrible health
conditions so this gurgling booming
America but where there's great
disparities between who's doing well and
and who's not and it's called gilded
because those who were doing well were
living very well right gilded as in a
gilded frame covered with gold this came
from a novel by by Mark Twain and that's
right it takes on the cast of this
extraordinary wealth
Rockefeller was the first billionaire in
America Vanderbilt built the biggest
house still the biggest house in America
during this period so the wealth was
people would make eight to ten dollars
in a week some of these tycoons were
making eight to ten dollars in the
minute and so that kind of vast wealth
because you could you could only make so
much wealth before this is just
mountains of wealth and then also again
this great disparity and it seems like
it came from really technology
technology allowed all of this practive
'ti the railroads steel etc etc and then
of course Finance was able to to get in
there and help move capital more
efficiently
what parallels do you see with our
current age where technology seems to be
doing something similar where we have
all of these new industries and a new
wealth but it but some fear that it
might be causing some inequality you
have you yes you have a couple of things
you have innovation in these various
different industries both innovation in
the creation of things but then also
innovations in the structures of
business buying up small businesses
creating big conglomerates then using
that leverage and power to then crowd
out competitors for sure but then also
to raise prices because you're the only
game in town
and you also have business practices
that are not the sort of the lays a fair
economic belief said essentially that in
the economy it was like in in the
American system which was let it operate
don't get in the way don't mess with it
because when it operates it runs the
most efficiently for America in the end
markets can be messy but they're gonna
have the best outcome that's right what
is the argument behind lazy fair that's
exactly right and it got this wonderful
assist from Charles Darwin who said we
can explain the growth of or you can
explain the species and we can explain
our natural world with these theory
about the competition among the species
and and this term survival of the
fittest
social Darwinism so survival of the
fittest which some and I certainly
thought might have come from Darwin
didn't it came from Herbert Spencer who
basically had an economic theory of
survival of the fittest and it went this
way some people have more talent than
others and when they exercise their
talent they do very well and that's the
bet
thing for society it believed that
society was ever-increasing it didn't
mean that every single person was
increasing but that if you followed
survival of the fittest and the best
people did the best then ultimately
society would always be on an
evolutionary plane of moving upward and
so that was the theory behind get out of
the way of these big companies and these
big tycoons and they will do the best
for America and so the reason that was
important was a it kept government out
of the way B it kept religious it
created a religion that it was a secular
religion of course but it created a
theory that said wow that looks like
what you're doing is totally
self-interested but there's this theory
behind it and everybody will improve so
okay go ahead yeah that was the
beginning of Gordon Gekkos famous greed
is good is good so the comparison to our
current moment is you have huge
disparity and and technologies that are
to use a cliche of the day disruptive
that are completely changing the way
everybody does business changing the
when we think about the way in which
Americans behave that rapid sense of
change it's changing culture rapidly and
it's making big winners and losers and
those big disparities are exist as well
how did the Gilded Age play out where
some of these forces moderated
eventually maybe around 1900 and and do
you think similar things might happen
for us there were two big moderations in
the in response to the Gilded Age you
had government came back came awake
again
and you had and then you also had labor
movements that came into into formation
basically to slow down the the growth
and the rapacious demands of the Gilded
Age politics during that Gilded Age kind
of went became an offshoot of the titans
of industry if you look at the
presidency between 1876 and 1892 there's
they're all one-term presidents and none
of them get more than 50% of the vote
and basically what the president spent
their time doing is you
using the spoil system which is
essentially putting people in jobs to
pay off the local bosses who help them
get elected so getting elected would
became a job of staying elected and that
meant doling out patronage basically
giving people jobs who were your friends
so that they would go and vote for you
because these elections are all very
close and that's not getting a lot of
work done for the people some of them
Rutherford B Hayes tried these little
efforts at civil service reform which is
essentially meant putting people in jobs
who could monitor the factories make
sure that people weren't getting abused
or that health wasn't declining or that
anything that a government might do that
we think of today but his political
patrons didn't want that so that was all
very hard to do what happened in the on
the workers end is they realized and the
and the most famous moment was in
nineteen eleven the Triangle Shirtwaist
Fire where a number of women working in
a garment factory are there's a fire and
the bosses lock the doors and I think 40
some-odd women died mostly women and it
highlighted the the labor issues but
labor labor unions start to organize and
there are huge clashes and strikes and
consumer boycotts and those start to put
some pressure on business to change
their practices at least in terms of
worker hours and and the kinds of things
that we now would certainly take for
granted
it's an incredible period yeah